continuing our look at the upcoming
congressional races in the general
election we're talking about district
one today colonel mark robertson joining
us we're running as a republican for
district one colonel good to see you sir
thank you john i'm glad to be here and
welcome to the world of politics you
were saying this wasn't something you
necessarily thought you would ever do
but you felt compelled to do it yeah
i've never ran for office before but i
felt i couldn't just sit back any longer
and hope that somebody else does
something about the direction we're
going let's talk a little bit about your
your background what is it about your
military service your your business
career that you think
suits you well
as a congressman well i'd say there's
three things first i have deep ties to
the to the district my wife and i raised
our family in the first congressional
district
i owned a business in the district
we went to church in the district
shopped
played i coached a little league in the
district so we have deep ties to cd1
two is i have national service i served
for 30 years in the army i enlisted as a
private and retired as a colonel one of
my last assignments was to the pentagon
where i served in the office of the
secretary of defense for policy so i've
worked on national level policy
and finally i have international
experience in those 30 years in the
military i deployed to 10 different
foreign countries including combat zones
in afghanistan kuwait and iraq and we'll
talk a lot about the military service in
a moment but first specifically with
district one you're talking about your
ties there
what do you believe is in district one
not being addressed by the incumbent
yeah so i've spent the last 18 months
talking to people in cd1 i've talked to
them in their homes their businesses
in in small meetings and grew in large
group meetings and over and over i hear
their biggest concerns and their biggest
concerns are inflation
crime the the poor education system in
in our in our valley uh the border issue
and water so those are the top five
issues that i hear from the people of
cd1 who they feel are not being
adequately addressed so how would you
address let's talk let's start with
inflation how would you address
inflation if you're elected to congress
good i have a degree in finance and an
mba in fact i taught finance at unlv i
know how the economy works and i know
how to fix inflation it's not that
difficult inflation is when there's too
many dollars
chasing too few goods we had
government spending
horrendous amount of government spending
printing borrowing and spending money we
didn't have and then we had a government
shutdown that shut down
our factories and so we weren't
producing the goods that people need
that will naturally lead to inflation
but in fairness you know whether it's in
the senate or in congress there's a lot
of smart people that get elected there a
lot of them have backgrounds in finance
what may be different do you think you
could provide to
uh other lawmakers to try and get things
done there and then also to the
constituents in district one that
they're not getting now yeah so as you
pointed out i'll be one voice of 435
and and so i will find other like-minded
members of congress regardless what
party affiliation they have like-minded
who feel like we cannot continue
printing borrowing and spending money we
don't have who support the idea of a
balanced budget at the federal level so
would you support a balanced budget
amendment or a make an enforcement of a
balanced budget and i guess looking back
what were your thoughts on the efforts
to put money into the system the ppp and
sort of the coronavirus pandemic relief
funding from the white house yeah well
there the audits are going on now about
all that money that was injected into
the into the system and so much of it
was wasted and fraud i mean we were
sending
stimulus checks to people in prison and
the stimulus checks weren't targeted to
the people who were most injured it was
just this broad
distribution of
money to people
and many of those people didn't need it
i talked to members of people who worked
for the government and they said i never
lost a paycheck i don't know why i got a
stimulus check they cashed the check but
but there was a lot of money that was
wasted and that's what caused the
inflation so is it as simple as raising
interest rates and cutting spending what
else would you want to see done in
washington yeah so
the the cutting spending is the big part
but also we've got to stop paying people
not to work right now we are paying
people to stay home and not work and
that means we don't we have a labor
shortage in the united states an
artificial labor shortage we've got to
give people
incentive to go back to work and you
stop paying them
and require they do they work to get any
of these benefits then it will solve our
labor issue let's talk about another
issue here that you mentioned is key you
believe in district one the issue of
immigration illegal immigration we've
seen some horrible stories from down on
the border the last couple of weeks
how do you think
illegal immigration is not only
affecting district one but the country
and what would you like to do about it
yeah so we see a flow of a a flood of
drugs gangs and guns coming across our
borders i have i have a personal friend
who lost his daughter
to fentanyl
poisoning and that fentanyl is coming
across our border it's not just people
it is drugs and and guns and gangs that
are coming across those borders those
affect the people in cd1 so what's the
solution we gotta we have to uh secure
our borders we've got to finish the wall
and we've got to use electronic
monitoring and then we've got to give
the border patrol agents the people on
the ground the resources they need to
keep the criminals out of our country
once we've controlled our border then we
need to fix our broken immigration
system
which is something that people have been
trying to do for as long as i can
remember and probably as long as you can
remember what can be done differently to
try and get that uh sort that out yeah
again i'll be one voice of 435 i'll go
over other people i'll look for other
people that will uh will join me in the
effort
some of the provisions that need to
change right now we have this lottery
system we spin the wheel and that
determines who comes into our country
that's no system we ought to decide who
comes into our country and they ought to
be people who can contribute to our
economy people who embrace the culture
of america and want to be americans not
some luck of the draw who comes in here
we ought to decide who comes in
uh you we've talked a lot about your
military involvement obviously your long
career with the with the military uh
right now there's a lot of effort a lot
of money being poured into ukraine right
now to try and help their efforts
against the russian invasion
at what point do you believe
either a american servicemen and women
should go into ukraine or b
that that money should be turned off
yeah good questions first of all i want
to applaud the people of ukraine they
have they have they are standing up for
the defense of their own country we
haven't seen that in the last in this
most several wars you saw the the men
the fighting age men in afghanistan
wouldn't stand up to the taliban to
protect their wives and their sisters
and and their mothers in syria you saw
fighting age men and women leaving the
country i i sat in a coffee shop in
turkey and and listened to syrians
complain
that we the americans weren't doing
enough to free their country as they sat
in a coffee shop in turkey so i applaud
the ukrainians for fighting for their
own country and i think it is the right
thing that we've been giving military
support but it would not be the right
thing to put boots on the ground when do
you think the
u.s
should stop is there at some point a
line where the us's would suggest would
say
we can't afford to keep doing this
anymore we can't afford to keep giving
billions of dollars to ukraine as noble
as the fight is yeah so so i believe i
think right now the u.s is playing the
lion's share of the support to ukraine
as far as
money and military equipment i think it
should be europe that said stepping up
europe this is the this is the doorstep
of europe ukraine is and russia is a
much bigger threat to europe than it is
to the united states and the europeans
ought to be picking up the slack and and
contributing significantly more than
united states you mentioned your time
being deployed in in japan and in asia
do you think the focus from a military
standpoint should be in the east instead
of in the west yeah it's a good question
and i think the ukraine war is showing
us that
russia's military is not as big a threat
as we may have thought it to be
but china's is and china is the growing
threat not just militarily but
economically as well
though the democratic the demographics
of china suggest they may not be a
superpower for long they don't have the
population coming behind to do that
let's get back to a couple of domestic
issues here uh recently roe v wade was
overturned by the supreme court
we know that nevada has it in state law
the the issue of abortion but if you're
elected into congress
is there any level of uh
abortion support federal funding or
anything along those lines that you can
uh
that you are in favor of okay first i'm
unequivocally pro-life i believe
with the majority of americans that
there should be limits on abortion that
abortion shouldn't be unlimited
and i i applaud the decision to overturn
roadway
roe versus wade not just because i'm
pro-life
but because it was the right thing to do
in our constitution even justice
ruth bader ginsburg said that there were
some issues and some concerns with how
the road decision was made so the the
road decision the overturning row put
the power back to the people where it
belongs it doesn't belong to the federal
government belongs with the people and
i'm surprised to see so many career
politicians complaining that power was
taken from them and given to the people
that's where it belongs do you support
though or do you agree that there should
be legal abortion at some level in in
the in uh in the term
in the term oh i know what you're saying
yes i do believe that uh you don't
believe in an outright ban
i believe that's right i believe in the
case of rape and incest and the life and
health of the mother that that abortion
may be the right decision
uh finally let's talk about uh the issue
of gun
control gun rights and and bills that
were recently passed in washington uh to
try and do something we've just seen
this horrible shooting that happened in
near
north of chicago recently
if you're elected to congress what
measures would you support for whether
it's background checks whatever the case
may be
on a federal level yeah first of all i
um my heart goes out to those families
at that parade my wife and i and our our
family were at a parade in boulder city
yesterday when this was going on and i
lived in highland heights my my little
brother was born there
i was too young to have any memory of it
but my heart goes out to those people
and we see this crime ray wave
crossing america and we've got to do
something to address this crime
the defund the police movement has taken
police off our streets and liberal
prosecutors have put violent criminals
back onto our streets we have got to
address the crime issue
across the country but also as i talk to
families in cd1 they too are concerned
about safety in their neighborhoods and
in their schools so if you're talking
about addressing the issue of safety
would that include putting restrictions
on who's allowed to buy guns and what
kind of guns they're allowed to buy yeah
so i would not restrict law-abiding
citizens ability to defend themselves
and their families but i would strongly
support prosecuting criminals who use
guns in in the con in
when committing a crime i also support
the idea of finding ways to keep guns
out of the hand as a mentally ill as
long as we don't take away their due
process right does it make more sense as
you're talking about putting more
efforts into prosecution does it make
more sense to put effort into
the aftermath of a horrible tragedy or
before in terms of getting guns off the
streets
would it make more sense to to do it
before the maybe before the crime
actually happens yeah we need to
prosecute
the people who are selling guns
illegally we need to stop the flow of
illegal guns coming in through our
southern border listen if you just take
guns out of the hands of
of law buying citizens that won't stop
criminals from having guns and so that's
one of the reasons i say we need to
secure our borders because a lot of the
guns are coming across that border so
yeah those are things that need to
happen beforehand and then tough
prosecution after the fact
colonel mark robertson appreciate the
time sir good luck to you in your race
in district one we'll be in touch thank
you john appreciate it